all right some takeaways Chris Christie
sounds like he's struggling to breathe
which makes it hard to listen to him
unfortunately hence does too bro he
doesn't sound like he's struggling
photography he doesn't sound like it he
is struggling and if he was nicer like
more friendly I think I'd really like
him Chris Christie I'm sorry he's such a
jerk no one should vote for for Chris
Christie yeah no one you know why it is
you know why yeah because he's fat and
sick
part of it if you can't take care of
yourself how do you take care of this
country true true and and and to be fair
the only the only pass Donald Trump gets
is not based on his health not based on
his diet it's based on the fact that
he's the closest person to firing people
who need to be fired that's it because
otherwise I'd agree on be like I mean
actually Trump did lose a lot of weight
what about what about that felt 215. yes
I read that in the news but what about
uh Taft it was a great president yeah
the biggest fattest guy ever in the
history of the world really it's
different when you get fat off of like
what people ate back then you know